[Music]
foreign
digital transformation is a tough thing
to explain
the way I try to explain digital
transformation to anyone is imagine a
river and you get to stand beside that
River as an advisor to a company and
constantly floating down that River are
little crates and in each one of those
crates is a new technology or a fad or a
new product and it's your job as a
company to quickly evaluate each crate
going down the river and identify does
that have something in it that can help
me does that have something in it that
could hurt me and how hard is it going
to be for me to jump in the river and
fish out the crate and drag it back and
try to make use out of it and that's the
really hard part and a company that
tries to reach every single one in the
river and pull it out is going to
quickly find themselves exhausted and
overwhelmed and have a hard time trying
to Cobble together what they just pulled
out of the river
a company that's falling behind says
that's energy and effort that's not
necessarily always worth it so I'm going
to just stick with what I've got I'm
going to let those Sail on past me to
the next person standing behind me on
the side of the river
but a company that's really good at
digital transformation at applying
technology for competitive advantage
is good at seeing that crate Float by
quickly deciding is that crate worth it
and then once I've got it on the shore
can I quickly put it to work so I can
get back to looking at the river and
seeing what's coming down
as a company if you have a center of
excellence of data scientists who are
developing things really valuable things
but they're hard for you to leverage in
other departments other groups or even
commercially publicly
connect in this context was one of those
that you quickly see coming down and say
like okay this is going to work to me
it's a little Underdog technology that
helps us Bridge a really big gap
foreign